[Musique]
lebron james michael jordan ou encore
kobe à bryant ceux des noms qui vous
font peut-être rêvé pour ceux qui
voudraient un jour devenir des vrais
stars de la nba
vous pouvez commencer à tréteaux à
mélanie il y à des écoles de basket dans
les yvelines où vous avez rejoint en
plateau pour nous expliquer tout cela eh
oui mickaël moi je vous propose qu'on
parte s'intéresser à une école précise
celle du plaisir basket club alors le
mini basket est une labellisation
régional qu'ils ont obtenus en 2016 pour
cette école trois catégories les moins
de 7 ans les moins de 9 et les moins de
11 ans un nom du responsable de l'école
en u7 nous on se base qu'elles sont sur
l'école de basket sur du ludique le jeu
apprentissage par le jeu
et ensuite le comité départemental des
yvelines met en place trois
rassemblements dans l'année pour que les
u7
voià sur un autre terrain font des
ateliers rencontres aussi d'autres
recettes des autres clubs plus face des
petites compétitions mais la priorité en
u17 c'est vraiment le ludique
l'apprentissage moteur du ludique certes
mais tout en apprenant quand même les
bases techniques et mélanie bah oui le
plus important même c'est d'apprendre à
manipuler le vallon de faire de la
motricité apprendre à dribbler à se
déplacer tout en gris blanc ce qui est
pas toujours facile il faut surtout
apprendre à tirer et j'ai rencontré des
joueurs de l'école sir et marquer
et faire des matches donne du côté du
papa c'est pour
légion
pourquoi
continuer sa marque et les pannes il dit
mais quel est ce que vous connaissez
george eddy oui bien sûr c'est un ancien
joueur je crois et surtout commentateurs
sportifs sur canal + depuis plus de
trente ans depuis plus de 30 ans et
surtout il était à plaisir ce samedi
puisqu'il est le parrain de l'école de
basket les plus jeunes
j'essaie de donner deux petites astuces
techniques qui peuvent éventuellement
les aider pour la suite
pour les peaux les plus âgés peut-être
des exercices de chou ma spécialité sur
le shoot j'étais basketteur pro pendant
15 ans et il est connu pour mon adresse
à trois points
alors l'école et bien sûr déjà victime
de son succès les équipes ont dû mettre
en place des listes d'attentes mais de
nombreux club yvelinois propose aussi
une école alors sont patientes sont
faits on prospecte un petit peu merci
mélanie pour toutes ces précisions